tonight President strums momentous
unifying address receiving widespread
praise and needless to say the radical
left their friends and the hate Trump
media they're not too happy tonight
wait'll we show you the reaction to the
and their analysis to the president's
pivotal speech and we have major
breaking developments tonight
surrounding Robert Muller himself
investigating the investigator shocking
news also for the Democratic Party and
what is going on in Virginia first it
began with Governor Ralph Northam
support of the grotesque brutality of
infanticide when he advocated for a law
or even when a baby is delivered living
on its own that he or she would be kept
comfortable and then the mother alone
would still have the right to choose to
deny the needed medical care to save a
human soul the essence of innocence then
the Democratic governor Ralph Northam
then he faced bipartisan calls to resign
but not for the cruelty and evil support
of infanticide but over another big
controversy his racist yearbook photo
which featured under his name in his
medical school yearbook
but after first apologizing for the
photo of the Klansmen in blackface well
then Northam then denied he was in the
picture at all and then a really bizarre
press conference admitted to well I
dressed up in blackface during a
separate instance and almost reenacted
Michael Jackson's moonwalk before his
wife thankfully stepped in citing the
inappropriate circumstances then a short
time later North terms soon to be
so-called replacement the lieutenant
governor Justin Fairfax well he found
himself now embroiled in a massive
Democratic Party scandal this is now
going up to the upper echelons of the
Democrats both locally and nationally
and earlier this week a college
professor named Vanessa Tyson came
forward with serious allegations of
violent sexual assault by lieutenant
governor Fairfax this dates back to 2004
the Democratic National Convention in
Boston now viewer warning what you're
about to
see is extremely graphic in a detailed
statement Tyson claimed quote as I cried
and gagged mr. Fairfax forced me to
perform oral sex on him
I cannot believe given my obvious
distress that mr. Fairfax thought this
forced sexual act was consensual mr.
Fairfax has tried to brand me as a liar
to a national audience in service to his
political ambitions and has threatened
litigation and given his false
assertions I am compelled to make clear
what happened NBC News Tonight reporting
this that the Lieutenant Governor
Fairfax himself responding to the
allegations and a private meeting
he actually said they quote him f that
be okay case kids are watching now this
just happened this week and while his
office denied the remarks the Lieutenant
Governor is calling that encounter
consensual now on this show we're going
to be consistent
unlike most TV shows and hosts we firmly
believe in the process due process the
presumption of innocence the very thing
the democratic party always denies to
any Republican or anyone that is
conservative now let's not ever forget
what they did to justice Kavanaugh
Democrats believe in guilt by accusation
no trials no juries just the court of
public opinion and for Democrats
accusations are disqualifiers for public
office and these charges against Fairfax
are beyond serious and unlike the
Cavanaugh accusations well in the case
of Fairfax accuser well they actually
were count a specific time date and
location and over the years
Tyson even confided with close friends
about this incident and what happened so
the big question now for the Democratic
Party is will they demand that
Lieutenant Governor Fairfax resign and
where are all those Democrats who said
they believe well the now debunked
accusers in the Cavanaugh case to
refresh your memory
look at this I'd only do women like dr.
Ford who bravely comes forward need to
be heard but they need to be believed
they need to be believed I just want to
say to the men in this country just shut
up and step up do the right thing let me
just say right at the outset I believe
dr. Ford I believe the survivor here I
believe her I stand with her she should
be bullied into this scenario I believe
her
I believe professor Ford I think she's
credible all right so where's Kamala
Harris tonight where's Spartacus cory
booker where is Elizabeth Warren who is
in more trouble herself after claiming
Indian heritage that she never had
Native American heritage where's Kirsten
Gillibrand do they believe this accuser
do they stand with all survivors of
sexual abuse or only when it's made
against a Republican or a conservative
is it just about politics not about the
cause because breaking today we have
more trouble in the Commonwealth of
Virginia the third now in line to be
governor Democratic Attorney General
Mark herring he's dealing with his own
devastating scandal that just broke and
earlier today herring announced that he
too appeared in blackface in the 1980s
so that means two-thirds of the
Democratic leadership in Virginia have
appeared in blackface and get this over
the weekend herring called on Governor
Northam to resign over the issue
so the question tonight is will he do
the same now in case you're wondering
the fourth in line to be governor
happens to be a Republican the Speaker
of the House of Delegates Kirk Cox this
could get very interesting we're going
to keep you posted on the dumpster fire
that is now the Democratic Party
nationally and in Virginia but first
let's turn to the powerful remarks from
President Trump at last night's State of
the Union where he promoted American
greatness urging political cooperation
getting things done highlighting the
people the principles the ideals that
make this country the greatest place on
earth take a look we must choose between
greatness or gridlock results or
resistance vision or vengeance
incredible progress or pointless
destruction millions of our fellow
citizens are watching us now gathered in
this great chamber hoping that we will
govern not as two parties but as one
nation the agenda I will lay out this
evening is not a Republican agenda or a
Democrat agenda
it's the agenda of the American people
all right those who saw the speech gave
the president extremely high marks by
the way record-breaking audience last
night breaking his record last year and
Obama's but now Speaker Newt Gingrich he
wrote this that it was quote so
effective and powerful that it changed
the trajectory of history and that quote
the emotions of Tuesday night matched
anything President Reagan achieved in
his address to Congress look at this
fake new CNN poll the American people
agree 76% of viewers gave his speech a
positive rating
CBS News poll seventy-six percent of
their viewers approved of the
president's remarks the State of the
Union obviously a resounding success and
one of the finest moments for the
President or frankly any president for
that matter one of the key reasons why
was this speech so powerful well it's
the success that the president has had
there's no shortage of real substantive
accomplishments that he has had in two
short years millions of forgotten men
and women their lives have been impacted
dramatically two years he's accumulated
a track record of achievement unlike
anything we have seen in modern history
record-setting tax cuts trade deal
energy independence that we never
dreamed of the best in 65 years
regulatory reforms a renewal prison
reform national security successes in
the Middle East Asia Latin America
Canada Mexico even our European allies
two Supreme Court confirmations from a
list he promised he would use an
American economy that is booming and
breaking records like never before now
for many of you even some conservative
friends of mine doubted is he really a
conservative well he governs as a
conservative and more importantly unlike
a lot of politicians he keeps his
promises I told you he would deliver on
the things he was promising to the
country during the campaign and make no
mistake it will be no different when it
comes to the issue of border security
that wall will somehow I can tell you
today exactly how it will be built there
are the consequences of neglecting
border security well that will be
catastrophic for this country in the
past two years alone we have witnessed
what is beyond a serious crisis not what
the Democrats or the fake news media
tell you a manufactured one in the last
two years alone ice officers brave men
and women that serve us every day have
made 266 thousand arrests of criminal
aliens including those charged or
convicted of nearly 100,000 assaults on
American citizens 30 thousand sex crimes
4000 murders homicides immigration
security officials they are now pleading
for help they want the strategic border
wall built they want to stop the 90% of
heroin coming into this country other
drug trafficking like fentanyl human
trafficking young girls being sold into
prostitution and other criminal activity
and that's why under the Obama
administration Democrats well they
didn't call walls immoral that's why
President Obama himself sounded an awful
lot like Donald Trump from last night's
State of the Union amazing
they support it when Obama's President
Obama sounds like Trump but now they
want no part of it why why would they
put their hatred of this president ahead
of keeping this country safe and secure
the life-and-death issue of drugs and
opioids and heroin and fentanyl what's
this tonight I am asking you to defend
our very dangerous southern border we do
have to have control of our borders tens
of thousands of innocent Americans are
killed by lethal drugs that cross our
border how do we get control over the
border that's become more violent
because
drug trade working class Americans are
left to pay the price for mass illegal
immigration reduce jobs lower wages they
end up being abused and that depresses
the wages of everybody all Americans
wal-mart President Barack Hussein Trump
Obama if Democrats continue to oppose
the border security because of just a
pure hatred for Trump the very things
they supported a few short years ago at
some point they bear responsibility at
some point the death the destruction
they are responsible because they're now
announcing I'm announcing and I'm
telling them they will become complicit
favoring hating Trump over safety
security life and death of you the
American people trafficking drugs murder
human trafficking all because that
border is not protected this should not
be a partisan issue
this should be a issue about life and
death and protecting the American people
and well look at the CBS News poll 72%
of you we the people favored the
president's points and point of view on
and his remarks on the issue of
immigration and sadly despite the
overwhelming approval from We the People
the mainstream hate Trump media singing
a much different tune taking their cues
from their friends that sat on their
hands last night in the Democratic Party
which is now the party of eliminating
ice and open borders higher taxes late
term abortions look at CNN fake news as
Van Jones wow what a great description
of the speech from him take a look I saw
this as a as a psychotically incoherent
speech with cookies and dog poop cookies
and dog food Wow because he works over
there and he worked for Obama over a
conspiracy TV MSNBC delusional Trump
hater at this point Nicole Wallace had
this to say
even before the speech was given let's
take a look I think that this president
walks in there and may as well deliver
the speech on his knees because that is
where he is politically there
losing it and another shocking display
of blatant hate Trump media bias well
the press overwhelmingly bashing every
single solitary part of the President's
speech and while so-called fact checkers
and PR Politico elsewhere desperately
trying to nitpick every claim
interjecting their opinions all along
the way
all four organizations that claim to be
unbiased and fair well this is not a
good look take a look Donald Trump
raised to a new level the demagoguery
the hyperbole the chauvinism and even
the misrepresentation on a lot of the
issues graphic language on abortion
Jordans substance a night of absurdist
theater as you try to hope for the best
you heard the rhetoric of divisive no
surprise the United States at this
moment in the world did not mention
climate change in even a sentence is
just frankly a disgrace if there is
nothing that was said last night that is
credible believable or memorable alright
just a typical night this is just one
more clear example the hate Trump media
is an arm of the Democratic Party
basically the propaganda arm and of
course one of the leaders Chuckie
Schumer rushed to the microphone early
this morning to trash the President's
speech let's look at what Chucky liked
what was just Chucky and Nancy standing
for president wanted safety security for
the American people life and death oh
they just stood for opposing him take a
look the president was political
divisive calculating even nasty at times
you know you can't talk about comity and
working together and give a speech that
is so divisive that just doesn't fly
predictable sad but that's who they are
hey Trump Democrats they don't seem
pleased about anything in last night's
speech no matter how bipartisan call for
unification uplifting make America the
greatest best place ever
president touting historic job numbers
Democrats 5.3 million six hundred
thousand and in manufacturing they sit
on their hands when they talk about
America's energy boom Democrats scowl
and when he spoke out against socialism
Democrats sneered and as congresswoman
Liz Cheney pointed out
Democrats had no problem clapping for
themselves it's all about them take a
look we also have more women serving in
Congress than at any time before
[Applause]
thirty-eight years of Obama they never
achieved what if Trump is achieved in
two years
maybe next year they'll also clap for
the strong economy the safety the
security of all Americans all right
before we get to our guests we continue
our Hannity watch on the deep state
tonight with huge breaking news
implicating directly now for the third
time that special counsel robert muller
the hills John Solomon who's going to
join us
Muller was hauled in front of the FISA
Court in early 2000 to answer for FBI
surveillance abuses many of them
reportedly included omissions of
material facts to the secret court in
other words exculpatory information as
the story explains former FBI official
Trisha Anderson told congressional
investigators late last year quote it
preceded my time with the FBI but as I
understood it there was a pattern of
some incidents of omissions that were of
concern to the FISA Court that resulted
in the former director Muller himself
actually appearing before the FISA Court
and the special counsel is declining to
comment does that sound familiar not
disclosing to the FISA Court that the
dirty dossier that they were told bought
and paid for by Hillary uncorroborated
put together by a Trump hater full of
Russian lies they never investigated
that former FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe testifying they wouldn't have had
a FISA application without the dirty
dossier and we have exposed night after
night Robert Muller is on a partisan
witch hunt look at the team of Democrats
he hired jeanne ray donated to Hillary's
PAC but even more importantly was an
attorney for the Clinton Foundation
partner Muller's team his pit bull
Andrew Weissman was at Hillary's
election night party and he has a long
record also withholding exculpatory
information and prosecutorial abuses
like in the case of Sidney count
Powell's book license to lie she'll be
here in a moment and remember Muller
hired FBI lovers struck in Page and we
all know where they stand they had the
insurance policy they thought
we should win a hundred million a zero
and of course all of this evidence isn't
stopping collusion conspiracy theorists
like crazy man Adam Schiff who's now
today expanding the scope of the House
Intelligence probe into President Trump
despite no basis to do to do so in every
aspect of his life and the president
reacted to shifty shifts move and here's
what he said I know what basis would he
do that he has no basis to do that he's
just a political hack who's trying to
build a name for himself and I think
that's fine because that's what they do
but there would be no reason to do that
no other politician has to go through
that
it's called presidential harassment and
it's unfortunate and it really does hurt
our country